Junto al colectivo de protección animal
red fauna de ciudad y una,
quiero invitarlos a todos y a todas.
Este sábado 20 de abril
vamos a estar realizando una jornada Nacional
de consulta pública de la ley para el trato digno
de los animales de compañía
en todos los Estados del país.
Tendremos puntos donde puedas acercarte y
junto a nuestros diputados y diputadas
de la asamblea Nacional
poder dar tu opinión,
poder llevar tus propuestas y tus ideas
para ser incluido en esta ley
que busca la protección,
la defensa y sobre todo el amor para nuestros animales
de compañía.
También vamos a tener jornadas de atención veterinaria
gratuitas promocionadas por el movimiento futuro
con vacunación
antirrábica sex tuplecanina triple felina.
Es la oportunidad de que nos encontremos
para poder seguir diciendo lo mucho que respetamos,
que amamos a los animales en nuestro país
y lo importante que son para nuestra sociedad